hello my name is Kelly Brownell and I'm
the director of the Rudd Center for Food
Policy and obesity Yale University I
welcome you to visit our website at
wwlp.com our commitment noted author
journalist writer for The New York Times
author of best-selling books including
how to cook everything and somebody
who's taken very strong positions and
visible positions on issues of food and
food policy so mark thanks for joining
us good pleasure going so you've talked
about personal policies regarding food
can you talk about what you mean by that
I think that it's it's one thing to talk
about what public health policy ought to
be like regarding food and of course
that's really really important but many
of us myself included field next to
powerless when it comes to changing
things on a grand scale I mean you can
call your Congressman you can if you're
in my position you can talk and a few
people lit will listen but for the most
part there's not a lot we can do to
affect public health policy but when it
comes to food I think there is a lot we
can do with our our personal health
policy and our personal food policy and
I think that that if we look at this as
a if we want to change the way America
eats we look at sort of two-prong attack
of trying to to make public health
policy be more progressive but also
changing the way that we so what do we
need to do I think the simplest way to
sum things up is to say there are three
things we need to eat less of and those
are processed foods junk foods and
animal products and there is depending
on how do you either look look at it
either one or five things we need to eat
more of the one thing we need to eat
more of his unprocessed plants you could
say five things because it's fruits
vegetables legumes whole grains and nuts
and seeds and as near to their natural
forms as we can make I'm not talking
about raw foods I'm not talking about
local I'm not talking about organic I'm
not really talking about any of those
things although they're all interesting
talking about eating
plants so it's it's it's helpful to eat
more plants but it has to be balanced by
eating fewer fewer animal products junk
foods and processed food and for me it's
been helpful to think of this as kind of
a seesaw and the typical American diet
has on the heavy side of the seesaw
eighty or ninety percent of our calories
is processed food junk food and animal
products ten or twenty percent of our
calories is unprocessed plants for many
people this may be five percent so any
progressive nutritionist will tell you
that the seesaw should look like this
ninety percent of your calories from
plants ten percent from anything else I
often say if you want to get that ten
percent from candy bars if you get the
other ninety percent from plants doesn't
matter but this is a big change not for
anybody this would be a big change for a
committed vegan this would be a big
change but for most people this is an
enormous change and I think the
important thing for people to recognize
is that moving this seesaw any any
amount in this direction is a really
good thing and if it moves imperceptibly
the first year imperceptibly the second
year imperceptibly the third year things
really change and I it's it's important
I think it's important to think that no
particular meal is that important no
particular day is that important no
particular week is that important
if your diet is moving in this direction
that's a good thing and I think that's
an important it's advice that that
applies to almost everybody in the
United States so everybody I know
certainly there's no one who couldn't
benefit from a little bit of that so I
know you've written that these choices
that you make about your diet day after
day week after week month after month
have implications for your health to be
sure but there also have implications
for the broader world there's a bigger
context here that includes the
environmental impact of how food is
raised so look when you were talking for
example about eating less meat I'm
assuming that that's a combination of a
health imperative and then
mental impaired but is that correct it
is you know if we're talking about
personal food policy I'm talking about
the health imperative for those people
who are looking for bigger issues or who
want a little extra added attraction the
UN is estimated that industrially raised
livestock is responsible for about 18%
of all global warming of all greenhouse
gases industrial raised livestock is
where we get all all but a tiny fraction
of our beef chicken pork and dairy and
dairy is a massive category because you
have to remember that includes you know
not only eggs and milk but all cheese
and cream cheese and yogurt and all that
stuff to the extent that you eat fewer
of those products you are actually
reducing your carbon footprint and this
is true universally aside from that
industrially raised not only
industrially raised the animals but
industrial industrial agriculture in
general has been harmful to the soil has
depleted our soil requires enormous
amounts of chemical fertilizer to
replenish it and ridiculous amounts of
water all of these things we're gonna
have to pay the piper on these things
eventually and I don't think it could
happen in our lifetimes it could happen
in our children's lifetimes or our
grandchildren's lifetimes but eventually
there's going to be a bill come due and
we are post what we personally are not
actively responsible here but we as a
nation are postponing those costs and
those costs are going to be tremendous
and if those costs were reflected in the
price of food we were buying now then
processed food and animal products would
be exorbitantly expensive much much more
expensive than they are now it would be
great if we could reflect those costs
even if we could symbolically reflect
those costs that is have a cheeseburger
that caused 99 cents with its real price
tag next to it whatever it is ten or
fifteen dollars no that that would
discourage consumption of
but though those foods are those foods
are costing us big environmentally and
someone is gonna pay for that whether we
want to or not that bill is coming do so
when you thought about personal health
policy I've heard you talk about the
importance of cooking in this picture
and people doing more of it why do you
believe that it's important well there's
an argument to be made that cooking
there's an argument the slogan would be
cooking solves everything which is a
little overly simplistic but there's an
argument they made that cooking has an
enormous impact and to the extent that
you cook you purchase your control you
look at every single bit of food that
goes into what you're cooking and
believe me no one could cook with foods
that are as damaging as the foods that
come in fast food and processed food
when you're cooking for yourself you
look carefully at what you're cooking
you take it into account and you want
things to move along quickly so you're
not using as many ingredients you're not
combining as many you're not looking for
weird things you're putting together a
few things and trying to put a meal on
the table furthermore you're less likely
to make unreasonably large portions
you're more likely to take leftovers for
lunch the next day and therefore improve
your lunches as well you're more likely
to adhere to the advice that you hear
all the time which is to say eat foods
that are lower in fatty foods that are
more natural if you're processed foods
eat more fruits and vegetables and
you're because you're able to have so
much more element of an element of
control over what goes into your mouth I
think you know there are secondary
things you could say well now you're
going to the supermarket and you're
looking at this broccoli and you're
saying well yeah you know I wish this
broccoli looked better maybe the farm
stand is better broccoli and now you're
looking for higher quality of things and
suddenly you're caring more about what
you what you're putting into your math
and I really think everything changes
for people who cook having having said
that I you know I recognize I
increasingly recognize that there's a
legitimate argument to be made that many
people do not have the skills or do not
have the time to cook I think it's
there's less of a legitimate arguing
that people don't have the money to cook
I think certainly there are people who
can't afford to buy ingredients and but
there are very very small minority of
people in the United States most people
can afford to cook the question is do
they have the skills do they have the
time the skills are gained by anyone
with any ambition from a cookbook or
they can be gained from a cooking school
and I'd be you know I'd be in favor of
public cooking schools the time is
another issue and it's a and it's a
difficult issue I mean I I haven't if
the average American watches 40 hours a
week of television I think that some of
that time could be sacrificed for
cooking maybe even five hours would make
a huge difference but these are these
are things that have to be talked about
and I think these are things that it
needs to be in a sort of open discussion
one thing that I think has come come
clear and what you're saying maybe
without the language specifically is
that people have developed as a distance
from their food psychological distance
physical distance where they're just not
connected with it very much and the
cooking that you're talking about seems
to close that distance that you you feel
it you touch it you work with it you
help turn it into something that you can
then consume and that creates of maybe a
healthier relationship with good look
everybody who's involved in this stuff
knows that if we cook the way people
cooked a hundred years ago we'd be fine
there was no diet on earth that a
hundred years ago was not would not
sustain in inadequate amounts because
100 years ago people had trouble getting
enough food that is not our problem now
there is no traditional diet that
doesn't sustain health if we all cook
the way our grandmothers cooked we'd be
just fine our grandmothers knew had a
shop they knew how to buy things and
they knew how to throw them together
we've completely forgotten that part of
that is we've become too busy but part
of it is that since World War two
there's been probably the most
aggressive marketing campaign in history
to encourage us not to cook to encourage
us to eat convenience food and eat fast
food and eat processed food and that
marketing campaign has been enormous ly
successful now at what cost at the cost
of our health of the cost of the
environments health at the cost of money
because it's cheaper to cook them too
I processed food and prepared food and
take-out food and so on and at the gain
to the big food corporations of an
enormous amount of profit billions and
billions of dollars of billions of
dollars a year in profit let me ask a
question about public policy related to
this the way when you'd start thinking
about how to deal with the nation's
obesity and diabetes problems some
people are approaching it by attempting
to get better food out there into the
system farmers markets - inner cities
better foods into schools but more
access with supermarkets poor
neighborhoods all these sort of things
are being done but you're basically
attempting to push good foods into the
system with the hope that then those
will displace the unhealthy foods other
people have taken a different approach
saying that we should get rid of the
unhealthy foods or at least decrease
their consumption and that will create a
void that healthy foods will come in and
fill you just one of those approaches
make more sense to you than the other
yeah I think I think they both make
sense but I think the second makes much
more sense and I think the second makes
more sense because as long as the food
companies have their way they will mark
it bad foods that are bad whether
they're bad foods are not they are foods
that in the quantities where eating them
are bad for us as long as that stuff is
flooding the markets that there really
is no room for better food we need the I
think we need the incentive of having
better food out there I think we need
the incentive certainly of having more
food available in more places to people
but I think we really need the
disincentive of saying look we have
decided that this we have recognized
that this stuff is not good for you and
we are discouraging its consumption in
its place eat this stuff over here we
also have the experience of the
government saying you should be eating
more of this kind of food without saying
you should not you should be eating less
of this kind of food we saw this in the
70s we saw this in the 80s we saw this
in the 90s when the government said we
saw this in the 90s when the government
said
choose lean meat or the government would
say choose foods that are less high in
fat and so people would say okay well
we're gonna eat more lean meat we're
gonna eat lean me from now on we're
gonna eat chicken and we're gonna eat
snack Wells because they're lower in
calories but nothing was eliminated so
the net result was our calorie intake
went up by what 20 percent in 25 years
we all gained an average of five or ten
percent of body weight obesity and
children doubled obesity adolescents
tripled grown-ups became heavier and we
have an obesity epidemic it's not enough
to say eat more this is why I like that
seesaw thing it's not enough to say eat
more fruits and vegetables you have to
say eat more fruits and vegetables at
the expense of animal products and
processed foods you have to eat fewer of
those good well thank you so much for
joining us I appreciate fun so our guest
today was authored Mark Bittman and I'm
delighted you could join us today please
visit our website at wwlp.com cast by
other visitors to the Rudd Center thank
you